[Music]
summer is a traditional time for family
reunions but one that took place in the
virginia countryside is a little
different than most the participants
aren't related by blood but they do
share a common bond all are descendants
of the african diaspora in its many
forms and are all making a living in the
food industry they came together to
share their finest dishes their common
struggles and ways to help each other
survive and thrive
last weekend
a communion of kinship
these foodies from across the globe
aren't connected by blood but by culture
and a love of authentic international
cuisine
it's all the brainchild of chef kwame
onwachi
this is all about celebrating black and
brown contributions to the food industry
this family reunion inspired by his own
afro-caribbean heritage is a food and
wine experience amplifying voices often
muted in the culinary world i wanted to
highlight all black cuisine you know all
food that stems from the diaspora and
you see there's chefs from nigeria here
there's chefs from trinidad and tobago
there's just from jamaica there's chefs
from atlanta from north carolina so it
shows how diverse we are as a people
on what she rose to fame on top chef i
haven't cooked with rock crab before but
it was fun i really liked the dish thank
you chef then opened his first
restaurant in 2017 but it closed in less
than three months he was executive chef
at the acclaimed dc restaurant kith and
kin for which he won a james beard award
until he walked away i left to own my
own restaurant that wasn't a failure to
you no i don't think any i think
failures are subjective you know
failures are something that it's a sign
by the person using that word you know
coming from the south bronx and being
able to hone a restaurant is a success
for so many people and myself included
so before we taste the great food let's
talk about the history for jamaican-born
chef andre foles success is all about
gaining more exposure for his country's
cuisine guys like spicy your mission is
to elevate afro-caribbean food jamaican
food absolutely why do you think there
aren't more fine dining establishments
that showcase those
and african-american food for that
matter it's hard when you don't have
that blueprint and even with mexican
food it took a while for mexican food to
get to where they are they still have
the best about being street and being
elevated so i think we're on the cusp of
pushing that bond when it comes to
afro-caribbean food so this this is a
three-day process for us the key to that
pole says is explaining the origins of
popular jamaican staples like jerk a
spice blend and a style of cooking
invented by escaped slaves known as
maroons in the 18th century
in this demo fols shows us how they
cooked meats in smokeless underground
pits they created jerk as a means to
survive because if once they're in the
hills and they catch those local games
and they pick those spices to marinate
their meats if they cook that an open
fire then that would give away their
position so they had to dig a pit bury
their meats and then it smoked it so it
preserved it and also secured their
location why is it important people
understand that history it's very
important because they will better
understand where we're coming from
and how deep these roots run for us and
that's why we're so passionate to share
that so once someone understands your
history and can better connect to you
then they better appreciate your food
and you're going to get some bananas
yes oh my goodness b-e-t co-founder
sheila johnson is co-host as owner of
salamander resorts yeah you got to see
this pig this is rodney scott over here
welcoming some of her favorite chefs
have you ever been to something like
this one never been to an event like
this before and it just feels good to be
here it feels like just what it's named
the family reunion i'm seeing folks i
haven't seen in years and here we are
with food
for johnson one of a handful of african
american owners in hospitality she sees
in this space an opportunity
we're going to talk about the issues
we're going to talk about not getting
financial support to keep our
restaurants alive
we're going to talk about minority owned
businesses how do we strengthen this
network
and that's what this is all about for
kwamiyanuachi
this is only a beginning how can
something like this change
the food industry in terms of diversity
inclusion
better understanding of all the cuisines
of the world i think an event like this
will showcase
so many different cultures and it also
shows that this food is wanted people
willing to spend money on this food so
why not invest more into our businesses
why not invest more into our people
there's so many different things that we
bring to the table which is the reason
why we deserve a seat at the table at
every table and if you're not going to
give us a seat at our table
then we're going to build our own
and that's what this family unit is
about
and this is not just
one event they're already planning next
years
it's really about networking it's really
about you know making a space where they
can say okay
here i'm having a problem
these are the solutions we found let's
help each other
create more space in this brilliant yeah
brilliant industry already getting
hungry and we still have seven
70 minutes to go why didn't we get
invited michelle
next year
we're coming hey we'll bring the dish
maybe maybe here you never know no i'm
not going to sing